上课啊，今天这节课讲什么？
今天这节课讲的概念啊有点空。
啥嘞？
叫复杂叙事。
复杂叙事，我为什么说这个概念啊有点空啊？
有点空哈。
是因为最近啊我在看禅宗。
禅宗里边说啥叫空呢？
非有非无。
非有非无啊。
就空还不是没有不是没有的意思。
空是。
既不是有，也不是没有，这叫。
费有废物。
所以我说复杂叙事这个概念啊。
就挺空的。
你说有没有复杂叙事？
也不能说有。
你说没有复杂叙事。
也不能说没有。
就很空。
咱这节课就来说一说这个空的这个话题。
讲复杂叙事，我们先来说一下啥叫简单叙事。啥叫简单叙事。
一个人。
或者说一个人。
一个视角，或者说叫一个角度。
一个事情，一个主世件。
然后。
现行虚势。
线性趋失或者叫线性虚势。
我写错了，但我不想改了。
大家理解这个意思就行了。
一个人物。
一个主角。
然后呢，大家跟着他的视角，就这一个视角。
要办成一件事儿，当然了，它里面有序列事情，但是本质上是一件大事儿，他要办。
然后呢，线性的讲从最开始咋样。
慢慢又咋样呃中段咋样，高潮咋样，结局咋样？
我们现性的讲。
这就是简单叙势。
咱们之前所有讲过的课，所有举过的例子和所有我对你们的要求。
都是。
这样的。
对吧。
都是。
所谓的简单叙事。
所以在这个过程中呀。
总是有同学。
要不明着问。
要么我从他的眼神儿飘忽的眼神里面能看到我每次说一个猪圈。
我现金去世。
给我一个视牙，我总能感觉到他有点。
这老师应该是就会写一个主角吧，两个他是不是就驾驭不了了，多个那就更完蛋了，那就没不会写了吧。
就老有同学有这样的疑问呢。
就老着急，老想说，那我们就没有复杂的吗？各种哎各种大倒叙，各种爱大悬疑，各种哎多个视角呱呱到一块儿，有没有那种故事呢？
有没有？
空啊。
非有非舞。
飞有飞舞，很空。
这节课咱们就讲讲这个复杂叙事吧。
非常空。
空是禅宗里面的概念吗？
修禅总有两种修法。
一种叫见物。
一种叫顿。
就说。
骗物。
啊。
动物。
建物呢就是有步骤。
慢慢。
今天那。
这这个修禅对吧？咱当然具体步骤，咱现在不是很清楚，我还没学会，就是他慢慢的悟。
顿悟呢就是嘎嘣一下，有一天嘿嘿嘿嘿哦这么回事。
这两种方法。
其实我觉得很多事情都是这两种方法学出来的。你不管学什么啊，都是先有个渐渐慢慢学，慢慢打基础的过程，天天在努力1点1.1点1点也不知道自己都学了什么，但是1.1点在学，突然有一天嘎嘣一下开窍了。
然后会觉得哇。
原来我已经会了。
就相当于你低着头爬山顿物的时候，一看哇。
往下一看，已经这么高了。
这就叫钝，写这边也是这样。
我前面给你教的那些东西啊，其实就是满满的引领你在践恶。
剑恶，你哪天能顿悟呢？
这个可能我控制不了。
就看你造化，但等你哪天顿悟了。
你再回头看我教给你的所有东西，我给你说的每一句话，你都会觉得哦。
原来当时老师是这个意思，是有道理的，没有说错。
或者是没有什么纰漏，滴水不漏。
只是我当时愚蠢。
我质疑了老师。
我跟你说复杂叙事这个东西它就是空的。
等你哪现顿悟了。
你就明白了。
今天我先给你讲一讲。
有什么样的复杂叙事？
好吧。
我说简单叙事是这儿，大家记住。
复杂叙事。
都可以从哪复杂呢？
首先我们看人物。
这个也是大家疑问最多的对吧？说老师你老教那些一个主角。
这个。
不够用。
比过不开呀。
我也想大站拳脚。
我不是跟你说了吗？
不够用的时候，你就给我把那个主角拆开。
而且拆的时候可以有个原则，就是往两头拆。
就是。
还有一个特勇敢的，一个特怂的。
一个特瘦的一个特胖的。
一个特乐观的，一个尿尿唧唧的，哭唧唧的。
就你可以拆呀。
我说那种角色本质上。
他是一个主角。
也就是说那种角色它不叫复杂叙事，那种戏不叫复杂叙事。我之前给大家举过例子，疯狂的外星人。
沈腾跟黄渤那两个角色。
那叫。
我们说那叫多人物，对吧？叫复合型主角。
概念啊我们主要是用来理解的去理解，不要去给我背概念。好吧，我说复合型主角，这俩主角是一个呀。
沈腾和黄渤，他是一个角色，所以他不叫复杂叙事。他在你写剧本的过程中，我这么说吧，假设你写疯狂外星人这个剧本，你有可能前五稿。
主角就一个人。
你是写到第六稿的时候啊，你会觉得。
啊，什么沈腾也来了，哎呀。
是吧。
给猜对了一个。
又给猜对了一个，很有可能是这种情况，或者当然也有可能是你觉得。
黄渤一个人有时候对话有点干，特别是就一个人的时候，他想表达自己现在什么心情，他没有没有出处，你知道吗？需要一个搭档。
有搭档这这种商业片喜剧片是有帮助的。所以说这种角色啊它不叫多人物。
那这种角色你说来。
在这种情况下。
对视角有没有影响？
没有影响。
没有影响呀，虽然多了一个沈腾，但是视角没有影响。
你还是站在黄渤这。
还是。
希望按黄花能不能耍成猴，黄花能不能拯救世界，对吧？事情是完完全全同一个事情。
完完全全同一个事情，沈腾没有单独离开干过一件自己的事儿。
他把猴偷走，想偷偷卖给于和伟。
那也不叫他的故事线。
那是他给黄渤制造的障碍。
给黄渤使了绊子。
所以他们俩从头到尾在经历同一个事件。
然后线性虚势。
疯狂的外星人。
看似双主角，毫无疑问。
简单叙事。
但是你非要去搞定义，你就说那有两个男主，他就是两个男主。
对吧而且他们俩性格不同，你非要去那么理解。
也可以。
但是我不希望。
咱们这一卦的咱们这一派的，咱们见物。
你听我的把这种理解为单一主角，再拆一个都行。
嗯嗯黄渤呃呃呃沈腾对吧？啊，电话突然来了，说，哎呦，宝强最近。
离婚挺闹心的，说想也想来演一个对吧？然后那一看那那都自己人呀，那来吧，那就就有可能那个又拆一个角色出来，让宝强演。
就一个来一个就是黄渤现在的人设，一个就是。
爱爱赚钱。
掉在田沿里的沈腾，还有一个就是一根筋。
跟谁都要干一仗的。
宝箱。
对吧。
他人家不让他们耍猴，不让他们开火锅店，他就上去打，说凭什么不让我大哥耍猴，对吧？他就去跟那个那个游乐场的经理打仗，干仗。那个外星人来了。
所有人都觉得应该软处理，就他跟外星人枪枪抢。
把外星人惹火了，是他。
你在外画出一个性格出来吗？
你说他是算又多一个主角吗？其实是一样的。
就这种情况下，他是没有变化的。
他还是简单叙事。我们说西游记。
来西游记那前也举过这个例子，我说师徒四人是一个人，对吧？
因为他跟沈腾黄渤一样，就是取经人的几种不同性格。但是有些同学会说啊，他说嗯老师嗯他不太符合你说的那种，从头到尾大家一条心嗯，一个事件，这是个例子。
孙悟空其中跑过一级。
哎，真有是吧？有一集被师傅给冤枉了，冤枉了以后呢，他就。
一生气回我的花果山，对吧？享享受去了，然后一集。
走了，然后后来又给找回来了，从打破平衡，然后又回到平衡。
你说那一集你怎么去理解呢？
你就把它理解为沈腾把猴低溜溜走一会儿。
就行了。
他在漫长的西游记里面。
他开了个小差，你就把它理解为猪八戒平时一直忠心耿耿，偶尔看到的。
美女，然后把师傅给呃出卖一回。
无伤大雅。
他在漫长的电视剧当中，每集那么写每集那么写，他有点boring。
他就来一个小俏皮，小调皮一下，作者小调皮一下，本质上他就是一个主角。一般来说啊，你怎么去判断来一个戏，这有俩角色，你怎么判断他是不是我说的这种复合型的主角。
啊，你就去判断他们有没有各自的人物弧线。
我上节课是不是讲过人物弧线，我上节课说人物弧线现在提的挺多的，其实它没有重要到让我们去参考着写作的那种程度，但是参考着修改。
当一个量尺去修改我们的一些东西，丈量我们的一些东西还是有点用的。比如说你在这里你就去丈量一下。
来，你告诉我沈腾有什么任务？
只能没有自己的人物弧线。
他的人不像跟黄渤是重合的。
就是这个意思。
呃，猪八戒有什么成长？
猪八戒没有自己的成长，其实他上来什么样，最后其实还是什么样？他只有一个共同的成长，就是取经人这个团队共同成长了。
就是他没有各自的人物弧线，我们就从咱们写剧本的角度说啊。
你就听我的在写故事的时候，你就给我写一个主角。
然后你再拆真正落成成片的时候，你再拆。
你拆6个都行，我都不拦着你，你只要这里放得下。
你把黄渤沈腾这角色拆6个，我都觉得。
呃，不奇怪，我也不会很惊讶的。
明白这个意思吗？就这类戏它其实还是简单叙事。你说它是复杂叙事，非有非有。
嗯，空很空，好吧。
西游记疯狂的外星人明白这个意思吧？咱们说这几年还有一类戏啊，也有点类似于复合型。比如说十一罗汉。
那种。
一听这名字，咱就知道他他他他肯定不是单一主角，十一罗汉呢是吧？还有什么敢死队？
啊，挺火的，其实更典型的还有互联。
复仇者联盟呀。
那多少英雄啊，各顶各的。
都是主角，对吧？谁也不让着谁。
你说你这种戏你咋去理解呢？
我就不说建国大业建党大业那些幻灯片型的电影了，那角色太多了。
你说这种片子他怎么理解呢？
你硬把它理解成。
多主角。
电影也可以，还是我说的非有非无很空的一件事情，你非把它理解成多主角电影也可以。有些教材上就是这么教的，就拿复联举例，说这叫新型的多主角电影。
我不同意。
我认为啊哎我们先就着他们的思路说，他们为什么说你看像十一罗汉，十一罗汉应该是抢银行吧，抢银行的一帮人。
来，为什么说这叫多主角呢？他们认为十一罗汉当中有好多个人有自己的人物弧线。啥叫人物弧线来着？就是人物在这个事件中的转变。比如说呃有一个人本来。
呃，很自私。
经过这次团队合作。
他找到了这个这个友情。
对吧会觉得多个朋友，多几个朋友挺好的，找到了友谊，对吧？有的人呢开始很贪财，后来呢放下了。
放下觉得呃钱无所谓，呃，人生有激情才更重要，对吧？就每个人都有自己的一一个小成长，你怎么去理解这个事儿？我对这个事情的理解啊，我认为那个小弧线太小了。
它不太构成弧线。你可以这么理解，就是说假设十一罗汉这个电影11个人戏份都很足的话，他们每个人的小弧线充其量就是一个小转变。
都谈不上大转变，谈不上彻头彻尾的起因革面，就是每个人都有一个小转变。在这个事情中，他们首先来。
这十一罗汉我们算他是多人物。
事情必须是同一个事情，就他们经历稳稳的经历一个事情。
这个不可能再裂开了，再裂开没篇幅了。而再裂开你拍一个电影干嘛？
各拍各的完了呗。
对吧。
然后呢。
我们来考虑这个视角问题。
考虑这个视角问题。
你看十一罗汉的时候，或者你看复仇者联盟的时候。
你的视角在哪里？
什么叫视角？
就你跟谁共情？
我们说呢单人物的时候，我们跟主角共且。双人物的时候，其实我们还是跟。
一个主动，一个同动的嘛，跟那个主动的主角，跟那个黄渤共情。十一罗汉的时候，他们一块去抢羊，你跟谁共情？
你跟团队共情。
你没有很在乎。
其中任何一个人的个人命运。
你甚至都做好了，十一罗汉，有可能会死他一个两个的。
精神准备。
而且他也真敢死，对吧？你其实是跟团队做共情。
凡是这种十一罗汉啊，或者复联啊这种啊。
他一般任务无限大。
就他的任务一般很大。
上来压着你。
吸了你所有的注意力，十一罗汉上来就告诉你这个银行有上亿的美金，多少什么金条之类的。
他用那个事情让你迅速的跟团队建立里共情。
你看啊他们几个，比如说先有6个的时候，这6个人决定合作。但其中有两个人貌合神离，以前有仇呀。
你不会站在任何一个人的角度，你心里想的是什么？你作为观众，你想的是你这麦俩能不能别吵了？
钱呀，我天哪，5000万呀，先抢回来不行吗？你们俩吵什么吵啊？
对不对？然后这6个人呢开始找十一罗汉吗？又开始找另外一个高手，另外几个高手，有的人不愿意加入。
你没有站在这6个人角度，你也没有站在那个人的角度，你还是站在团队的角度，哎呀，赶紧的吧。
为什么不能一块儿，对不对？
所以这种戏啊。
你从现在我给你讲述的这个角度，你去理解，你去顿悟一下，你试着去顿悟一下，你还觉得他是个多主角的戏吗？主角其实是团队，团队有目标，团队遇到的。
外部困难。
好呀太难抢了。
团队遇到的对手是看守银行的那帮FBI还有银行那帮很凶恶的银金融大佬，对吧？然后内部的。
这个团队自己的抗争就是内部搞分裂。
互相还不和不和睦，他俩还有爱情，拖后腿，对吧？
你有没有发现主角其实是团队。
所以写十一罗汉的时候，你在写故事的时候，你再按照我教你的方法，写先写八二元素，再写十序列的时候，其实你还是按照一个人在写呀。
你完全可以按照一个张三要抢一个银行。
全部都写完，然后心说好嘞，我把张三分成11个人一样。
一样，只不过他自己与自己的抗争这一块，你用来写成这11个人之间的矛盾。
然后你说呢这11个人在一个长达2小时的电影里会不会有变化，会不会有成长？
肯定会有一点，肯定上来。比如说一个老黑特别粗鲁，总是说他妈的对吧？你以前在监狱里面对吧？他们都是刚放出来嘛，你以前在监狱里面跟我有仇，对吧？就老想说我不帮他，我不要跟他坐一个车。然后最后在关键时刻。
有有队友牺牲了，然后这个老黑放下成见，跟他这个之前的这个仇人，这个油墙滑掉的小白脸，两个人就一块共进退。你说这是他的成长吗？哎，是。
我觉得充其量算是变化，不算人物弧线。
所以这种你说十一罗汉复联这种。
他有点就每个角色确实不一样，甚至出场时间都不一样。
对吧有的先进场，有的后进场，你非说这是复杂叙事吗？
他有很复杂吗？
我们不要去卡定义，对吧？你不要去给我卡定义说哪一类叫复杂叙事，是就是不是就不是。我们是是要学写剧本，复杂叙事不是定义以外的复杂叙事，是能力以外的复杂叙事。它超出你能力了吗？
写11个罗汉。
跟你写一个人抢银行难了吗？我没觉得难了。
搞不好还简单了。
对吧。
就是他没有超出。
我们说的一个人物，一个视角，一个事儿现进叙事没有超出去。
还是。
在范围内。所以。
从定义上说，你说。
你非得去去卡课本上定义说他是复杂叙事，那他确实不止一个人。
好说是不是复杂趋势飞舞。
但是呢你说难写吗？真的复杂吗？非有。
非有非无，很空的很空的，这些都理解了吧。所谓的就是我跟你们说的这种复合型的这种。
其实真的不用去太过在意他。
他呈现出来可能是乌泱乌泱的好几个人。
十来个人都有可能十一罗汉嘛。
我跟你说，写的时候就是一个张三。
很有可能在那个第一稿，第二稿里面就是个张三好。
那我们就来讲一下。
真正的。
这个所谓的。
不是一个人物的戏。
有没有？
当然有。
最简单的来说，那么爱情吗？
爱情片嘛。
爱情片不就得至少俩人吗？
是吧爱情吗？
我们来说爱情片。
或者叫友情片，爱情叫友情片。
很多就真的是。
两个主角。
而且有的甚至。
会有两个视角。
我们找两个片子来看一下。
这种所谓的复杂叙势。
只有多复杂。
有没有那么吓人，比如说爱情片。
泰坦尼克泰坦尼克和大家想着点剧情吗？
我也是靠回忆啊。
因为这几天实在是挺忙的。
我就不一个一个片子回看了。
我就用大脑。
来给大家回忆一下。
我们说。
泰坦尼克的主角是那个。
jack和rose是吧？
卡布料和那个那个那个ros。
一个穷小子。
一个附加女。
一个穷小子想往富人堆里扎。
一个富家女想解脱。
所谓。
上流社会的束缚。
很互补的两个角色。
然后各自表述。
这克是在。
呃，赌场出场。
赢了个船票，然后最后时刻上传。
这部戏这两个人物你说有几个视角，我认为。
泰坦尼克号。
做到了两个视角。
就是男人会带入迪卡普利。
的角度。
因为他太潇洒了。
他的人物弧线太完整。
然后女人呢。
会带入带入rosose的。
的的角度。
因为他。
的处境一上来也是非常的让观众揪心。
就是那个。
一本正经的未婚夫。
对吧然后他呢想挣脱这个束缚。
也让女性观众很有同理心。所以我认为泰坦尼克号其实他做到了两个视角。
他做到了一个标准的爱情片能做到的。
男代入男女代入女，所以他要做到这两个人的人物弧线各自完整。
就是每个人的智理事件是分开的。
就这种戏啊，我们看。
低卡不料。
赢钱上传。
然后呢。
那个roose应该是。
跟家里人发生摩擦，他的出场应该是各自的干扰事件。
是分开的。
然后两个人第一次相遇是。
roose站在甲板边上做事要跳海的那种感觉。
从那里才开始汇合。
汇合起来之后，两人经历的事情。
开始有有大部分的的事情开始重合了，但是还是在完成各自的序列。
啥意思呢？就是这个事儿对于。
迪卡布料。
可能是个转折。
但是对于。
那个那个roose。
他可能是个危机，也就是说两个人的经历了一段各自的弧线之后。
在冰山。
撞船的那一刻。
重新。
恐怖它的前半段是个爱情片，后半段是个灾难片。我们说。
泰坦尼克号啊可以载入影史。
它是载入影史级别的电影，它肯定不是简单的呃一个商业片的概念。它前半段是标准的爱情片，后半段是典型的灾难片。
就他都处理的很很好，衔接的很好。
然后呢，他其实就做到了两个人物。
两个视角。
然后。
大事儿是一个。
然后线性虚势。
然后也不是纯线性啊，是开始是分开的，最后合在一块了，等于是这样一个呃叙事就能明白。
啥叫复杂叙事？就稍微复杂那么一点。
复杂叙事呢其实。
还是从弧线角度理解比较好。
就是说杰克和rose各自有各自的弧线。
弧线是。
是分别的，但事情不一定，就就像我说的，事情不一定。
是分开的。
就像那次他们冲到。
底层。
他们有一场。
呃，这个杰克带着roose到。
船舱底部其实就是最低等舱，那里两个人嗨起来了，喝酒跳舞，与民同乐呀。
对吧。
来。
这是他们俩共同经历的一件事情。
这对于男主来说其实是日常。
这件事情对男主来说是日常，就这件事情是他俩共同经历的。但是这件事情在两个人的人生当中的作用，两在两个人故事线当中的作用是完全不同的。
是完全不同的。
他对于男主来说，在底层是日常呀。
底层生活是他的日常。
然后。
对于女主来说，相当于是女主的庇护史的起点，就女主看到了另外一种生活的可能性啊。
明白这意思吧？就同一个事儿，但是序列不一样。
在各自故事中的位置不一样。
那相同的迪卡布料也也也西装革履的上了一层。
上面呀你跟这种牛逼的电影，它都是很对仗的。迪下不利奥牛逼穿上西装。
跑到顶层甲板参加上流社会的舞会，对吧？这对于迪卡普利。
这序练又跟那个那个跟rsose的又不一样了。
所以说。
泰坦尼克号。
他就是。
两个人物。
两个视角。
然后呢，这个线性叙事呢就不是那么现了。
不是那么现了。
你可以从事件上来说，他们俩基本上经历的是共同的事件。
就从试卷上你可以说是一条线，但是。
序列人物弧线。
是分开的。
我们说友情片也有这种类型的。我我前面说过啊，友情篇其实跟爱情片是一个大类的。
是一个大类的友情片我们也可以找一个例子。
找一个大家比较熟悉的。
太久。
太囧是徐峥跟王宝强。
在。
路上。
去去泰国的路上相遇，两个人本来抱抱着各自的目的去泰国，然后呢在飞机上相遇坐邻座嘛。
开始纠葛在一起，一起经历完泰国的旅程。
然后。
互相成全，互相帮助，互相影响，互相圆满，共同成长。
都完成了各自的人物弧线。
这个片子就是典型的友情片。
他的视角是什么？
他的视角在徐峥，泰囧的视角是在徐峥的，王宝强没有夺走。
没有几个人看这个电影的时候，站在王宝强那里，希望王宝强完成那个种树，完成那个大部分的共情还是给了徐峥，是为什么？是因为大部分的爱情片和友情片其实也是有主动和从动的。
我们说泰坦尼克号的主动当然还是想放在迪卡特利奥身上。但是因为。
詹姆斯卡梅隆导演人家是大师，他呢就是玩的比较好，他没玩那么偏，他不想让你跟着一个角色走到底。
对吧但是像泰囧，他在影史上的地位，那肯定是没有呃泰坦尼克那么高，当然也是非常好的片子啊。
他呢就是很标准的。
做法很规矩的做法很规矩的做法，在这种爱情片，友情片一般是俩人嘛，一般是俩人，一般是怎么做啊，还是会做视角人物的。
我其实前面不应该先讲泰坦尼克号，泰坦尼克号没有那么典型。
泰囧才是最典型的这类片子。
就是他会做一个主动人物。
徐峥这个人物是一个主动人物，以徐峥为主。
宝强为辅。
徐峥的事情是主轴。
婚姻的压力。
公司的压力，然后呢想去办成这件事情，各种困难苦衷。后面呢黄渤是个追兵。
对吧还有对手，其实所有的困难目标动力全在徐峥身上。
但是这个片子还是有情天，因为宝强是有自己完整的人物弧线的，他也有自己的目标。
对吧也有自己的困难，也有自己的苦衷。
然后最后也实现了他的目标，就他的人物弧线也是完整的。但是呢相对另外一条人物弧线呢稍微小那么一点点，没有那么大的弧，但是太久。
啊，确实是。
双男主。
就说这种片子虽然一一组一从，但是这真的是双男主。
因为他是爱情片或者叫友情片。
当然他用友情片套套了一套出一个公路片，就泰囧，为什么好看也是有道理的。它不是纯友情片，他也是套了一个公作片出。
你看这种你就理解了吧。
然后泰囧呢因为视角比较比较轻松的，泡在一个视角上。
对吧他是两个人物，一个视角，然后一个事情。
典型虚势。
宝强基本上没有离开虚峥，就两个人的故事线基本上没有分开。
而且两个人的序列也是重合。
并没有各自表达。
遇到困难的时候是两个人的困难，遇到成长的时候，基本上也是两个人的成长。就是说。
我我讲这两个片子啊，为什么讲这两个片子？就这两个片子是一个类型的片子，爱情片、友情片一个呢做的比较规矩。
一煮一从。
然后呃序列高度重合。
另外一个呢。
就做的稍微花哨一点。
视角呢看起来更丰富一点，就是这两个视角它都代入了，但本质上其其实是一样的，都是所谓的。
两个人物。
然后。
一个视角或者两个视角。
那你玩这个两个视角是有点冒险的啊。
两个人物一般来说，一个视角，一个事情先惺虚事。
这就是爱情片和友情片这个大类在这里单独拿出来讲，就是因为他是真的是多主角，他可不是拆出来的。
就这个不是拆出来的。
这个宝墙不是拆出来的，写的时候就是这么写的。
因它是有用的。
他完整的虚钟虚峥。
就这种片子在课本上他是怎么写的啊？他他写这类片子的要素是。
课本上的定义啊。
就是一不太完美的主角，就是主角要缺一块。
明白这个意思吧？主角是要缺一块零件。
然后。
再给他配一块零件，这就是书上是这么描述这类片子的。
就一个是主角，一个是零件，相当于。
徐峥是主人公。
视角人物，但是呢他有明显残缺，他掉在前沿里了呀，他掉在前沿里忽视亲情，对吧？这是徐峥的明显残缺嘛，人性的残缺。然后。
王宝强这个角色。
是零件儿。
他什么都不懂，什么都不会。
十种亲情。
直动亲情，他只要。
他妈妈好。
除了这一点以外，他什么都不懂，甚至有点傻。
所以说这个泰囧是比较雕科书类的这种友情片。
一个有残缺的主角。
配一个。
能弥补这个残缺的零件。
大家明白这种。
所谓的多人物。
爱情面有情面。
你说他复杂吗？
我觉得也还好。
这么理下来。
也还好，并不反复。
其实就是确实各自有各自的弧线了。但是呢事件是重合的。
序列。
基本重合。
你能玩出多少花？
看你的本事。
你把序列真的给它完全瞪开。
但是你要瞪得漂亮。
那你可能就玩出泰坦尼克号的这种虚势。
所以说。
这种片子我就讲这么多。